[Music]
thank you
the what podcast which spans this year
that matter Lord Taco Barry quarter I'm
Brad uh nice to see you again guys of
course uh in the festive spirit is uh
Sam to Jackson Santa Taco got my hat on
can we go back to what we just said a
few minutes ago where you said I was
smart
can we revisit that I'm just thank you
very smart yeah and then of course
you've got Santa very festive rust chat
Lord Taco Russ Jackson but also the
latest member of sprockets is here Barry
Corner what is this outfit you're
wearing trying to just be a floating
head is it working
[Music]
I just want to be a floating head uh-huh
yeah you're the you look like sprockets
where's your tiny little round glasses
yeah for some reason you're some sort of
like troubled poet today
what is this you're wearing
I swear to God a taco if he comes in
with a beret next week quitting
immediately oh you know what's coming I
got the Santa hat all he needs is a
beret a beret and an ascot and yeah my
man is ready what's everybody been up to
wait oh pipe is nice walking stick could
always be yeah
helpful what are you guys been doing
what's uh what's new what's happening
been missing you how you been
I asked you first oh I don't matter um I
mean like everybody else been dealing
with the the flu and the illnesses and
all that but whatever you had the flu Oh
yeah oh it's best
oh yeah oh yeah Thanksgiving
Thanksgiving was spent in the bed but
you know ever I'm not complaining I'm
alive
okay all good now do you guys remember
the day that I gave you covid
yes we were the first three coveted
patients in America uh I got the worst
flu I've ever gotten that December 19th
uh December 2019 was 2019 or 28th 2019.
I can't remember now 19. oh God it was
awful I've never felt worse uh and then
you know a couple months later covet
explodes I'm convinced that we all I
gave all of you covid yeah I think Russ
was next right yeah but mine was just
the flu I mean there was no covet test
at the time but uh right I was positive
for the flu I think it was flu there was
a or b and I don't remember which strain
it was but I mean it was it was the
worst flu ever
kicked my ass too I remember putting my
head on a pillow and thinking I will not
wake up tonight
I
remember I think that every night
well you're supposed to think that way
you're supposed to live your life that
way so thank you
yeah it was me I appreciate that I uh
I'll tell you I was really upset because
that was the weekend I was supposed to
go to La for the very first ever Harry
Styles show and I was like even up until
the moment the flight was taking off I
was walking around the house like I
could go I can make this and he was like
you're not get you can't get on a plane
like this I was really bummed out and I
mean look it's Harry Styles I I it's not
like I'm the biggest fan in the world
but I wasn't gonna miss the first ever
show in La for Harry Styles I wasn't
gonna miss it that I missed it if you I
can't hang out with you guys instead
yeah I can't even believe you had that
much energy
that I just remember like if I'm not
going anywhere I don't care um
so so let's start this uh this episode
with uh what we know so far uh we've
gotten some real clues in the last
couple of weeks Taco take me back and
explain to me who what when where and
why with the Rook first rooku was who
was it oh it was um
Chris Chris yeah it was Chris yeah thank
you uh yeah that's too tight yeah I
can't can't get all the the brain just
doesn't want to stay in there um yeah
Griz which uh which was interesting
because we had Grizz do the Super Jam
last year
um I don't even remember that I mean I
wasn't there so I I kind of totally
forgot about that to be honest no no
wait no uh Grizz did the Super Jam was
it two years ago right
um yeah it actually the one that
actually didn't actually happen or is it
just listed no hmm I think he's done two
I don't know
how much
it raises an interesting question how
much of this is a reset before we even
get too far down this road how much do
we care how much do we care who's been
there in the last two or three years
I don't I don't yeah yeah I mean I know
yeah if it was on the 2020 lineup and
they made it or didn't make it I don't
care bring them so you know what I mean
I think I think that you I I don't think
that that goes for you know if they were
to book Stevie Nicks and Tool
you know but but I don't think anybody
cares if churches comes back or if you
know Robbie rich is there
um that's what I'm asking yeah it's fine
yeah it's just weird to uh you know they
tease us with uh who's gonna be there
and then it's it's somebody that we kind
of all expected was going to be there
anyways yeah the great Super Jam by the
way is 2019 2019 yeah last year yeah
um it was the it was the goat a
celebration of music legend Super Jam
with Grizz right featuring uh Owen Berry
Stu Brooks Nicholas Patricia
hobo Johnson Etc yeah I'm not I'm not I
I and that's why I ask I I think a lot
of us uh it sort of hit like a pause and
a reset kind of thing you know what I
mean
um so I know where we're we're going to
talk about who we want and all that so
well the other the other the other uh
real clue was Odessa right no that was
is it Odessa no that was a leak from the
festival oh okay oh you mean you mean
the news that we told you months ago yes
I'm glad you finally got to break news
that was already broken oh God this guy
well
he we could have tweeted it just like
just like he did
oh well why would we would write long
it's a conversation for another show
um what was the other what was the other
group I think it was a band called
m-u-n-a okay yeah I have no idea yeah so
yeah I don't I don't know them either
but I know people uh I got I mean we
have a friend a mutual friend that
absolutely adores them so okay uh I mean
that's a big deal another Roku coming
this week anything else that came around
that we
may have known those news this past week
or last two weeks did I miss anything
else uh as far as lineup just yeah that
where what tier two I know not as far as
lineup but yeah how did the original
sales go by the way do we know I think
they went well yeah we talked about on
last week's high five they're now into
tier two which I guess is a good sign
right I mean that means they're moving
at least you know enough tickets of
course we don't have any idea they could
yeah
20 we don't know I know tier one could
have sold 50 tickets but you sold out of
tier one yes yeah it's gone
so but we do know but we have heard that
uh you know the old as we're now calling
it the flea and T or the flea and tick
uh Woods Place uh where we used to be is
very popular
Russ and I have decided we're going to
call it flea and tick oh are you yeah we
even though there are no fleas and there
are no ticks well we can't stay there
anymore so we're down
just trying to dog this thing out so
people don't buy it so you can move back
up because that's where we screwed up we
were two two we were too nice about it
you're right we oversold it we really
don't want to be there that's that's
where all the bees are that's where they
they harvest the bees that's exactly
right yeah there's so many bees nests
back there
it's gunks skunks so the other thing too
that uh when we go through this week
when we go through I I want to go
through our wish list go around the room
and see what bands we really want to be
there uh now that we are fully into uh
rumor and speculation season I mean we
are just a couple of I mean it feels
like six weeks are we probably six seven
weeks away from a lineup uh when does it
usually come out mid-February did we did
we nail them down on this January
January oh it's January really yeah I
think you were pretty adamant it was
going to be like January 15th or
whatever middle oh did I see somebody
somebody called what's his name festival
and tell him he can break that too uh
uh okay yeah well I feel like he he sort
of alluded to that too in our
conversation a couple of weeks ago with
the C3 guys the other thing too that I I
keep coming back to what he says this
lineup feels like Rue to him it feels
like Bonnaroo again whereas maybe the
last yes he did say that and by last I
mean Machine Gun Kelly yeah no I no
question and I I think
um it's been it's been a little while
since you've been on with the russ and I
we've done a couple of
um high five clips and the last time we
talked
we sort of agreed and I want to ask you
you know back in June at the end of June
we said this next lineup has to be
killer it has to be amazing uh I think
we I anyway have backed off a little bit
on that in that it needs to be good and
maybe even great but it doesn't have to
be killer
um
and how do we Define that that's what I
would like to ask you you know I mean
it's also subjective these things are so
subjective the person that loves the
hangout lineup right Chili Peppers sza
Calvin Harris Paramore there's another
person that thinks it's total trash
right
um so
I feel as though that they're their
biggest job this year is to reignite the
passion for the brand
um it can't just be another lineup it
can't just you know be a a year that
they it feel where it doesn't feel
connected again and I think their
biggest their biggest challenge is going
to have to reconnect with the Bonnaroo
faithful and I think that they've
started by all indications based on the
conversation that we had with them a
couple weeks ago that's what it feels
like they've started to do you know
they're re-engaging the fan base with
the the multiple tiers and the different
type of camping options I think they
know the challenge right I think they
see it in front of them and they're
addressing it now whether it is is
shown through a lineup that we all like
who knows
I feel pretty confident that this lineup
is going to be really good and I feel
really confident the people that are
putting this Festival on that they
actually care about it the way that we
care about it whereas maybe in the past
it felt a Ted surgical maybe a tad
sterile I feel like the I feel like the
the feeling is back I feel like the the
love and the feeling that we all have of
this thing is is is back I think uh
disjointed would be the word I would use
to how it felt last couple and I think
to your point and it goes back to what
we've seen is a good word yeah what
we've talked about and what we
discovered
um if that's the right word I I don't
mean we but we at we talked about on
this show is Lanes that's what it feels
like to me is they they understand that
they need to have artists that fit in
certain Lanes they fit uh headliner on
down you know like if Brad likes the
headliner what does Brad need to see
earlier that evening and earlier that
evening and what else is on the lineup
that would interest and I'm just you
know using you well and it feels like
last this this year uh 2022 there was
like it just felt like no Lanes right
exactly yeah that's what I mean
disjointed I mean I think I think this
joint is a really good way of putting it
um yeah where I where I think it's
sterile you know it lacked the sort of
the emotive feeling and the the
connectivity that that we all have with
a I think disjointed is it works as well
um so if you had to what is Barry's
number one
artists that he wishes for for 2023.
it's easy you guys know I mean I'm I'm
an open book It's My Morning Jacket
I think they are I've said it since
2007. they are the perfect Bonnaroo Act
they always they were they and they
still are uh in my mind now there's a I
have no I have a number two but we'll
wait now but I'm gonna go I'm gonna
stick with that we'll let you guys
answer but all right My Morning Jacket
is your headliner Taco uh wish list for
me I mean if it's just if it's just a
pure wish I'm gonna go Tears for Fears
okay didn't see that coming I did not
either why not
I don't have a problem with it all right
raise it I go for the Beatles
as well
yeah
okay uh that's your wish list fine by me
all right all right I'm gonna go I'm
gonna let that go because it raises a
part of the question that I want to get
to later so yeah who's your who's your
number one Brad well I'm trying to look
at the Tears for Fears tour for 2023 and
uh and just you know what kind of
concert dates they're doing
um and currently no concerts near
America uh for Tears for Fears in 2023
so it looks like their schedule's open
that's that's why it's a wish list yeah
my
absolute desire number one is a band out
of the UK that doesn't necessarily do a
lot of uh doesn't do a lot of shows but
I don't know if there's been a more
proficient artist in the last three
years through the pandemic to now
they've put out what 11 albums they did
Five albums just this year
the band is salt s-a-u-l-t
um I am absolutely obsessed with this
band
um they're doing a lot of their stuff
just via the mail they don't really get
together all that often and they sure as
hell don't do many shows but I heard
wildfires a few years ago and since I
heard that song I've Been
um
I mean holding my breath that they come
to the states and do any sort of
Festival date because I will be there
immediately I I've got to see this band
I've got to see this band at some point
I hope in 2023 everything's setting up
for them to
explode and I I just want to be there
when when it happens but I'm obsessed
with them s-a-u-l-t it's salt is that
number accurate or are you exaggerating
Five albums yeah so they did Five albums
this year as sort of like a gift to God
and one album is called air and it's all
orchestral ethereal sounds
um they did uh four other like they the
the amount of product they are put they
put out this year is out of control and
it's almost hard
fantastic it's absolutely fantastic no
11 to me is one of my favorite albums of
the year
five in like six years so they were all
pretty good I mean so they are really
they released Five albums at once and it
was only available for a few days on
their website that you could download
totally for free
um and then it they took it down and you
can't get them anymore but then they
eventually found their way to like
spotify's and
et cetera I have I I respect your your
opinion no question about it so I I look
I think 11 was damn near my favorite
album of the year
um I
I would start with with wildfires and
then why why why uh those those two
songs are probably my the best entry
point to this band but
um today and tomorrow came out uh the
same day as earth air
there's actually two albums named air if
I'm not mistaken
um they've got an album named nine that
they released earlier this year
they released let me look it up here
they released nine air 11 air Earth
today and tomorrow and Untitled all
since June of 2021. I think you're just
making words up
thank you it sounds like a made-up
Netflix I just put out an album It's
called uh air
um
uh Aaron two eyes
we loved it so much we did it twice wow
yeah but the way the way that 11 starts
off with glory is just so so strong
um I love this band so much uh so that's
my number one uh wish list item that I
can give you Barry quarter your second
band that you absolutely want to see
Bonnaroo 2023 anything with Warren
Haynes
I don't care which band he comes with it
can be him by himself well I hate to
break the news here but sources tell me
sources
playing with tears to fears this year
see this turns out this is the song all
working out yeah
he's that's probably the only band he
hasn't played with uh-huh uh Lord Taco
your second band that you want to see
second one I'm gonna go with is The Mars
Volta and I know we're getting them for
Shaky Knees and I'm super excited about
that but I want to see him on on the
farm
so you are our resident shaking these
guy I've been to a few times but you
love shaking did that line up that
lineup came out yeah yeah we talked
about it I think you weren't on that one
but yeah the lineup came out and it's
great the best that I've seen
it's a good lineup yeah I would I would
I could say I'd be happy if this was the
Bonnaroo lineup I would too I would yeah
well that brings me to the second band
that I am absolutely fighting uh tooth
and nail four is the AAS yeah
um my uh one of the great shows I've
ever seen at Bonnaroo was that yeah yeah
show uh on the witch stage it could not
have been hotter oh my God that show was
so hot it was so packed and you know
karano swallowing the microphone still
to this day I I will not forget I want
them back on the what stage this time
and I want them
and a little bit cooler of an atmosphere
uh maybe six seven o'clock uh so it's
not nearly as hot this time but um I
love that show at Forest Hills I uh and
there's not a band that I want to follow
around the country more uh in 2023 than
the AAS Barry quarter
uh you know I'm looking at that so
wish list I'm gonna say Flaming Lips
make a return I'd love to for a Flaming
Lips reunion another perfect another
perfect Bonnaroo Bank when was the last
time they were there was it the Dark
Side of the Moon year because I remember
that I've got a crazy story about that
year at Bonnaroo but I am I missing
something were they they
have they been to Bonnaroo since that
Dark Side of the Moon year no I don't
think so and in fact this is going to
blow you away I think the last time they
were close was that Riverbend here in
Chattanooga I was there at that show and
it was very uncomfortable it was very
uncomfortable they're also on the show
they're also on the Shaky Knees lineup
yeah that's yeah uh so that Sunday night
and I'm jumping all over I I won't say
it but yeah that shaky knee lineup is
pretty good well there's a little
addendum to their name on there it says
performing Yoshimi Battles the Pink
Robots
oh that's fantastic oh it's fantastic oh
I'd kill for that
um so last time I saw Flaming Lips they
the Dark Side of the Moon um it was 2014
right I'm standing on the stage the side
stage of the witch where Flaming Lips
are doing their show and then Kings of
Leon had done like the the main stage
right before that so you get like Leon
Leon or Danny Leon or whatever their
names are like the brothers walk up on
the stage holding a plastic jug of
whiskey and in tow with them is McLovin
so I watched the Leon guys and McLovin
just chugging Whiskey on the side of the
stage to the point where like uh now
it's time to getting it's things are
getting a little itchy McLovin threw up
off the backside of the stage
he was there for half an hour chugging
whiskey until McLaughlin had to throw up
um man I love that year I love that show
so you'll never I'll never forget Wayne
coin coming by with his megaphone just
screaming at us
is uh my introduction to Bonnaroo
because in 07 I'm pretty sure it was
either seven or eight but I think it was
seven
um you know I don't know I had to go
cover this event which I you know I
didn't want to camp I was scared to
death it was raining it was hot it was
everything and I went on back to bed at
whatever midnight
and I'm I'm in my tent and I can still
see out and I'm next to the I'm in the
field next to the witch stage and all of
a sudden I see this giant inflated ball
come off of the stage with a guy in it
and I'm like what the hell is happening
I gotta go see this and then I went I
mean then I was out and I think yeah
from then on I was completely bought in
this was unlike anything that I had ever
seen before and would ever see and don't
go to bed early and that's what I mean I
know
but I mean I couldn't believe it I was I
I could even describe it to you know my
wife or anybody's like you're not going
to believe what happened but so the
thing about that ball that's so
interesting is is you mentioned
Riverbend them coming to RiverBend years
ago and you know they get this ball and
they travel on top of the crowd and he
walks in this ball like a hamster wheel
on Earth yeah part of his birthday well
uh well he tried to do that at Riverbend
in Chattanooga he did that down the on
the ground there weren't any people
there
and so he literally was he had to do the
ball thing on the ground because there's
only like 10 people in this area that
they couldn't hold him up
he crashed on top of people and they
sort of like stared at him in this ball
well looking like a total strain is it's
one of the strangest interactions I've
ever seen in a flaming lip show yeah
let's be fair okay because here's the
deal so he it's a it's if you've never
seen the show they have a screen and
it's a whole birth thing and he comes
out and then he's in this ball and he
literally walks in the ball out onto the
audience on a normal stage Riverbend is
horrible because it used to have this
barge that went 60 feet down to nothing
which is what Brad's talking about so
he's down he would drop down to their
credit they got there two days early and
tried to figure out how to figure out
how to do something different for
Riverbend so you probably didn't like it
because you hate Riverbend I just it
wasn't it wasn't it wasn't good
to their credit they tried to make
something work yeah and by the way too
for a side note it was 2010 it was 2010
that they did Dark Side of the Moon on
um yeah it was not 2014. yeah it said
last time there's 2014. we got we got
Barry and Flaming Lips Lord Taco your
third band you want at Bonnaroo 2023. uh
number three I'm gonna go with uh
editors
all right Taco introduce me to the
editors who are the editors Mr radio I
don't I don't
know why is it by the way if radio guy
doesn't know a certain band it's like
why are you even in this industry
I'm not loud
I'm laughing at your reactions do you
know anything
there's no we've said it before there's
no way you and I can know everything I
don't have a problem with that I'm just
laughing at your face
hey you're useless did I hear that right
you're seriously so tell me about
editors because this is not ringing it's
not ringing about let's look it up let's
see
okay
editors are an English rock band formed
in 2002 in Birmingham previously known
as pilot surprise snow field
playing consists of Tom Smith
Russell Lech edley okay they got some
members
um yeah
all right so to revisit learning about
the editors they have some members and
they're from two Platinum Studio albums
okay got it uh it looks like they're
doing some uh dates in the Netherlands
and turkey and UK in 2023 so who knows
um maybe maybe Bonnaroo is in their
future tube or taco maybe
um my third artist this uh actually is
because I just saw
um this guy added to what was the
festival that they just got added to
uh oh summer camp summer camp in
Illinois I want to see I can't believe
I'm saying this out loud and Barry's
Eyes Are Gonna Roll back so far in the
back of his head they might fall out
Willie Nelson hell yeah I would have a
blast at a Willie Nelson show mainly
because I I think you know I know his
best days are behind him I don't know
how many more willing Nelson shows we
got we haven't
I hate to say it could be another John
Prine moment where you know if you don't
see him
you might not get another chance
this might be it this might be it I
really I've seen Willie once and it
wasn't very good yeah um and I don't I
don't anticipate this being very good
but I really wanted to see it for the
moment
I I my eyes are not rolling back and I
get it and it would um his son I think
two sons actually I think but one son is
doing more of the singing uh yeah really
okay you gotta see Willie while you can
um I would highly recommend you know
pulling every string you can trying to
get on the bus with Willie I'd be
interested to hear that story uh because
I keep hearing more and more stories
about Willie and his bus
um I've seen Willie many many times and
I'm I'm so glad that I did so I you know
I don't have a problem with that but
okay it's he he can't sing anymore yeah
he can still pick a little and just
seeing the guitar I mean just being able
to say you saw Willie in the guitar yeah
yeah and the other thing too another
thing too at Bonnaroo is that the amount
of people that would come out of the
woodwork to want to be on stage with
Willie it almost turned into its own
Super Jam everybody loves he
that's a good he might be number two
behind dolly
as far as like everybody loves Willie
yeah any genre you know celebrity
basketball football whatever everybody
that's a really good point do you know
who might be three I would almost put
Snoop number three yep and William Snoop
weirdly enough this they're they're two
peas in a pot you know have you ever
heard about each other Snoop says the
only guy that can outsmoke him is Willie
yeah you know I mean to me to me to me
that would be that would be a really
great moment of Bonner and something
that could almost uh turn into its own
Super Jam uh Barry quarter number four
man all right I'm I'm going with the
obvious here but I'm sticking with it
and I'm also looking at Rail bird and um
by the way sold out apparently yeah
that's great just because I'd like to
see because and because I missed the
Bonnaroo show Nathaniel rateliff
and the night sweats I'd like to create
that yeah
um it's a great show yeah
you know and again there's two there's
three or four on my list uh that I could
have picked that I'd be happy with but I
think that's one that's me too so my I
saw Nathaniel at uh Tipitina's at a tiny
Tipitina's is a tiny venue in New
Orleans
um on a tiny stage then years before
that I saw him on the Music Midtown
stage
pouring down rain
and Nathaniel rateliff in the rain one
of my favorite shows I've ever seen in
my life
um I I just like a big muddy pit for son
of a [ __ ] was just an absolute blast
and I didn't care I mean you know me
yeah I don't I don't do dirt I I didn't
care it was so much fun that's why I say
I think he's a perfect Bonnaroo
brainy whatever you know we've we've
talked about this for years there are
certain bands that just sound like a
certain time of the day for Bonnaroo and
Nathaniel rateliff as the sun's going
down that is the to me what a perfect
soundscape that would be exactly all
right Lord Taco I can't wait for this
one let's hear it the dead stinkies
how did you know
um I don't know this little band I I
heard like a year ago I guess uh crumb
they're they're pretty neat
um they've got like a really trippy
they've got like one of the trippiest
videos I've ever seen
first of all
you know what what this really means
she's got a great voice
what does this really mean what does
this mean Taco in the bus with a radio
on yeah spinning records yeah that's
that's what it's end up being I'm going
with
um a band that I have seen way too many
times uh and every time I see them it
gets better and better I don't care how
many times I've seen them and I'm seeing
them again tonight the LCD Soundsystem
um still still my favorite moment in the
history of Bonnaroo was 2016. it was my
favorite lineup I know it was not well
attended
um but that 2016 year is my favorite
Bonnaroo year I've been to out of 20.
that was my favorite Bonnaroo show I've
ever seen because it was the first time
I saw them when they got back together
um and this residency has been an
absolute
dream so last year living in New Orleans
um when they announced this residency
last year and then had to cut it short
for covid I kept saying all I got to do
is get up to New York I gotta go see one
of these LCD shows I've got to see it
part of the reason I live here part of
the reason why I moved to New York not
only is it the the tip top of my
industry but it's because of things like
this I was so irritated a year ago that
I couldn't be a part of going to any LCD
night that I wanted to just on a whim I
was so irritated about that that that
was part of the reason why coming here
was so attractive saying to myself well
at any moment I could go to an LCD
Soundsystem show right and I'm actually
getting to do it this will be night four
out of 18.
um I my magic number is has has always
been four I'd like to get to five if I
can before this Run's done but my magic
number is four and every show has just
gotten better and better and better
um I I I I've got so many great memories
of that 2016 year and the LCD show is
right up top I I want it again I wanted
just one more time at Bonnaroo I'm gonna
send you a picture Taco one of my
favorite I've taken about four pictures
that I'm really proud of at Bonnaroo and
that's one of them is it of Me no
um so why are we talking about it if you
remember how that show started it came
out it was completely dark and uh I'm
I'm in I'm up there in the pit taking
pictures I'm like I'm getting nothing
there's no way I'm just just keep
hitting the the button and the next day
in our in Camp Nut Butter I said all
right let's go ahead and download these
and see what's up and the third one I
got the greatest picture because they
brought that big glitter ball remember
how it came out it's called a disco ball
disco ball
glitter balls ball it's the same thing
it's a but anyway it's I in what world
have you ever heard a disco ball called
glitter ball
it's a glitter ball it's a disco oh my
God okay anyway
make sure you wear that banana skin when
you go see the glitter ball
fair enough fair enough anyway it's one
of my favorite pictures and it was a
complete accident so it was a great
sweater ball glitter ball oh God my
favorite Mariah Carey album glitter ball
yeah
that's why I have an idea I I I've told
this to uh their management but I've got
this idea for an LCD show and I must
have been in a different mental state
but the disco ball the glitter ball is
their calling card right it's on all
other merch I want them to do I want
them to set the stage up as if they're
inside the disco ball
you know where like the walls can come
in and close in and then it turns into
one big disco ball the walls can come
down and inside the ball is nothing but
the the like the screens that's behind
them and the lights that come out from
oh what a great idea
um
okay but you know between between this I
might have some ideas about it but
between this and The Flaming Lips This
is the most ball heavy show we've ever
done
yeah what is that ball called yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh solving all your ball needs the
podcast four balls about balls
uh and one more let's go around the room
one more Berry core to your final uh
band for your wishlist 2023 or again and
it goes back to what I was saying
earlier I could have picked from any of
these
I'm here in hosier's show and album is
really good I could go with that or The
Lumineers and I can't believe I'm saying
Lumineers because I was not that big a
fan a lot of stomping and clapping like
stop being clapping huh just clapping
yeah I'd rather go with Hozier
I think Hozier and I and I also wanted
to mention again I'm looking I'm pulling
off of these two lists but I want to say
Future Islands just because it gives
Brad
about a half hour's worth of rant
material so why you don't like them I
love Future Islands
oh my God what are you talking about
okay no you're confusing the fact that I
had seen Future Islands a few times and
I just don't need to see that show again
no I need more better or otherwise look
no the show is great but his act sort of
wears thin after you've seen it a couple
of times I love Future Islands okay it
was one of my go-to shows for like ACL
and Bonner that the the year before that
I love it but after you see it a couple
of times you just don't need to see him
pounding on his chest and ripping his
face off and going through the
performative art that he does not take
anything away from it it's a great show
but after you see it a couple of times I
don't really need to see it that's fair
enough uh
I mean God there's a couple others well
that's all you got you're done you're
out of you're out of wishes
I I can't wait for this Lord Taco you
find a one I don't wish thank you good
ready all right hear me out
um I and I've because so far so far it's
so easy yeah
um and I've talked about this before but
uh Pet Shop Boys
I want to have Pet Shop Boys Super Jam
um I've seen like there's a YouTube
video of them doing like a medley of
their songs it's like some awards thing
they kept bringing out uh they you know
they brought out branded flowers they
brought out Lady Gaga
and I mean it was just hit after hit
after hit and I think it'd be super fun
to have a super jam with Pet Shop Boys
and you know special guests
I mean that is one of those bands Barry
I I don't know if you've seen them
um uh they they sort of live in The
Ether for me as just one of these I'll
never see I guess I'll never have an
opportunity to see them and I'm I'm glad
you brought that up because going back
to what I said at the beginning it's
only because it's been on my mind and
I'm gonna ask you guys and you can make
fun of me or not I don't know that it
works but I'm fascinated with this
Motley Crew deaf leopard tour
is that way out of no way Bonnaroo or no
way no way too yeah I mean I don't think
it works either because they're already
touring but would that be in any way a
legacy type of act one or the other
I've seen them both I saw Motley Crue
during the Tommy Lee drum rotating thing
back in the 80s you know I say my
initial reaction is absolutely not but
then again we went to an Alice Cooper
show and it was awesome it was fantastic
yep um so maybe maybe I maybe I
overreacted and thought a little bit too
quickly that's me and that's why I
brought at first it mean when I heard
they were doing this
such an Oldies But Def Leppard Def
Leppard is one of the shows that I saw
back in the day in the 80s that I didn't
want to go to and I'm so glad I saw it
it was great it's 90 minutes of just fun
yeah and you know every song you know
every single song and everybody next to
you knows every song but by the way Taco
your Tears for Fears wish is uh
unfortunately going to die on the vine
because they are in Paris and London
during Bonnaroo 2023. so you're saying
there's a chance
[Laughter]
maybe maybe another year
sure sure by the way have you ever
noticed that with all the you know
people who have like in a world now in
2023 2022 where like names are out of
control people are just naming things
the most bizarre names like yeah people
have ridiculous names
why has there never been one person
named Santa
other than Santa
you know you can there are people who
are still naming their kid in Germany
Adolf but yeah we can't get a kid named
Santa I never went to school with a
Santa did you I never went to school to
Santa no I can't believe it's not a
major sports star the name Santa as many
as me ridiculous Jesus and yeah that's
good uh so my final one is going to be
another band that I have seen um
multiple times and I'm going to go see
them again tomorrow night but I feel as
though I want to be a part of like
um their explosion and uh that's why I
tried to go to as many of these shows as
possible because I know it's just going
to keep getting bigger and one day
they're going to be
um one of the biggest bands in the world
wet leg
I want to see wet leg at Bonnaroo I've
seen this show on small stages at
tippettinas I'm going to see them at
Webster Hall this week
um talk about a show just keeps getting
bigger and bigger when I saw it at
tippetin as it was 35 minutes right they
had one album worth of stuff I even told
the girls like hey I haven't thrown in a
cover or two uh just but you know it's
tight these girls are so sweet they're
so much fun
um yeah so uh I wanted to have their
Bonnaroo moment but that's that's it
that's my wish list those are brought
them up I was going to ask you about
that
um because I know you've seen the show
I I mean I love I love uh Chase Lounge
uh the song
yeah what okay I know I love that song
and I love wet dreams even better I mean
yeah on DVD that was going to be my
question this is such a fun show yeah
yeah and what I really loved it so I
came back to LA mistakes a lot because
seeing that Bonnaroo show and then
following them around the country and
seeing it 15 more times throughout the
next couple of years watching the
progress every time they got on stage
and trying different things and seeing
how this thing was going to work and how
to preserve her voice Etc that kind of
stuff was so much fun to watch
um to eventually you know
some of the final shows where it was
especially Bonnaroo when they came back
to Bonnaroo into the what stage it was
such a big giant show at that point
um I feel like I'm on the ground floor
of this wet leg thing and seeing it uh
get a little bit better and a little bit
better a little bit better is so so much
fun so rewarding anybody out there
listening who's not familiar it's this
their their sound is everywhere it's old
it's new yeah it's retro yeah just I
love it I'm with you the the songwriting
is so quirky and and interesting um I'm
such a big fan yeah I love these cars so
much we're going we're going to LCD
tonight together oh nice yeah they're
they were so excited they planned their
entire system when they booked this uh
these five dates in uh New York they
decided to come in a few days early to
go to an LCD show nice cool yeah very
exciting all right uh let's uh take a
quick thing we'll take a break and then
we'll come back uh wrap up uh with some
news from the past couple weeks someone
to get to and we'll wrap the show up
next hang tight
[Music]
so well that that we touched
back in the go that lineup was announced
uh you know we've said it year after
year there's no more Randy Newman's on
the hangout lineup I'll never forget
going to hang out and sing Randy Newman
um there's that ain't never coming back
this is a very very young Festival
um as it should be it should be a top 40
uh young kid hangout uh no pun intended
Chili Peppers says uh Calvin Harris
Paramore Lil Nas X then you get down
into uh you know the bands that I would
actually want to go see it's rainbow
kitten surprise backseat lovers I really
like that Betsy lovers band
um and then you know some things that
actually work really well on the beach
literally a band called Beach weather
um so that came out you got the uh rail
Birds sold out and then you have
um the Shaky Knees lineup that I haven't
uh I haven't talked to you guys about
you really like the shake it easily it's
amazing how shaky it is every year
and just it's one of those like you the
more you look down the list you you keep
getting surprised because like wow okay
just yeah I can't remember a shaking
these lineup that I was just like meh no
they're all great every year but every
year this one for me really knocked it
out of the park
the only thing that it seems to have
um and for you and I don't mean to put
words in your mouth Brad but it almost
kind of has a I like this day more than
that day uh you know I would go not
maybe not all three days but I would go
two days that type of thing but this one
this one's pretty strong start to finish
um it really is yeah I think I mean
Cypress Hill in and of itself is getting
me another Friday uh yeah all right I
know in the Yeah Yeahs and The Killers
which is a great show
um yeah it just it feels like
the the the the festivals are figuring
out their Lanes
right well I mean in in
well shakinis has always been really the
reason why I like shaking these and the
reason I like hang out so much is for
that exact reason they know exactly
Their audience and they super serve that
specific sound that they're looking for
um and personally Shaky Knees is is
always right in my wheelhouse but I
really appreciate what hangout does they
know the audience so well and they they
super serve the people that show up
there
um I give I give both of these vessels a
lot of credit
um Shaky Knees now I don't know the new
venue as well as I knew the old one do
you like Central Park I like it but I
don't I don't know what the hell venue
was so I don't really can't compare it
but uh yeah that's fine
um the other thing that I wanted to get
to is it feels like we are I mean this
close to an actual Coachella lineup and
correct me if I'm wrong has anyone heard
a peep
of a leak when it comes to a Coachella
lineup no I've got I've got a pretty
good handle on what the Bonnaroo lineup
is going to be but I haven't heard a
single peep about Coachella
no not me because have I missed anything
you pay much more attention to that kind
of thing than I do okay but but you
haven't like taco you haven't heard
anything about no rumors about no and if
you haven't then I certainly haven't so
uh yeah and then the final thing that I
want to get to is
um something near and dear to my heart
uh
19 year old Brad could not have been
more excited 20 year old Brad could not
have been more excited this week when
Postal Service announced their reunion
to do 20 not just postal service but
going on tour with death cab and getting
the whole band back together with Jenny
Lewis and you know Ben not only doing
the the Postal Service album but
transatlanticism two albums that
completely defined my twenties
um that was I I have never been happier
or more giddy I love Parker's the ruhim
kid ruham won his reaction was just
curled up in a ball
so that's exactly how I felt I I got
wind of it earlier in the week and I
just started texting everybody I know as
a guys uh this is this is really
happening I'm so excited about this yeah
it's pretty cool yeah very funny that I
saw the image hey one thing before we go
and I wanted to just mention it uh we're
gonna get into tips and all that stuff
in in future shows but because of the
timing of it we got an email from Nick
uh from Australia oh yeah I wanted to
bring this up I'm glad that you reminded
me about it the timing was right because
I'm he may be asking for Christmas gifts
or whatever you know so I wanted to
bring it up but his question was
basically uh what about the shuttle uh
he's coming uh I guess with a friend or
a partner whatever and wanted to know
whether to uh it was worth staying in
Atlanta and taking the shuttle and going
to Bonnaroo and uh I mean I'm not going
to answer it for you guys but my my
response would be no no yeah that's
Amelia I was going to say yeah so so
read the whole email just just so that
everybody understands what he's asking
um so that I got it we're all on the
same page my girlfriend and I are
heading over to the States from
Australia next year for Bonnaroo I've
been listening to your podcast clearly
you guys feel camping at the festival is
a huge part of the experience our
initial plan is to stay in Nashville
take a shuttle from to and from the
festival each day is that a bad idea I
love Nashville and I suppose we were
hoping to get the best of both worlds
accommodation and food in Nashville
Music at Bonnaroo
so
yeah we're all in agreement yeah that's
that's it that's a no for me dog
um that's it's a I don't think it's
gonna work out as well as you think it's
gonna work out it's just that is way too
much work
um but I don't even know what that looks
like seriously I don't either okay but
guess what that looks like but B you
cannot like it's not just part of the
experience
it is the experience you break the seal
you break every you yeah you have to go
in even if you're if from Australia and
it sounds to me like you know you got
some money so just get the package buy
the package and let them set up the camp
for you and you just enjoy it Nashville
I can promise you ain't going anywhere
right and it will be the same it will be
the same J crew on Thursday then it will
be the next Wednesday and then the next
year it's it's not gonna take your
National time some other time uh or you
know it's a double double book yourself
and get the back end trip to Nashville
and spend a couple of days or if you
love country music do CMT Fest the
weekend before but don't try and do this
back and forth thing I I just I don't
think you're gonna be very happy with
either experience no by the way whatever
you think you're going to be doing in
Nashville late at night is you're
missing Bonnaroo you know that's right
that's right so yeah I don't even know
how that looks I don't either because
three o'clock four o'clock in the
morning you're just just now I guess I
guess we'll go back to Nashville and do
what well you missed the shuttle leaves
at one I mean so and if you missed the
shot is it really yeah I think I don't
think I knew that yeah it doesn't run
like 24 hours
you know you have to you have to if you
miss the shuttle you're sleeping on the
ground yeah don't do that don't yeah I I
would I would implore you and beg you to
just let go and have the whole Bonnaroo
experience yeah yeah the only the only
reason I can think of to take the
shuttle is if you're just one of those
people that only wants to see one or two
yes if you go one day you want to go one
day and maybe come back for early
tomorrow yeah
otherwise but even then I would but even
then Barry I would even I'd just bring
my car
I'd rent a car and sleep in it yeah no I
was just going for a day I'm just that
one person who just wants to see you
know whoever artist a and you know maybe
experience a little bit of uh what you
think is you know hippie fast Woodstock
whatever that's the only reason I can I
can take a break in the show otherwise
you're missing Bonnaroo all right
anything else to get to uh I wanted to
do a little personal news for on the bus
um bus update bus update
um there's a shop in St Louis that I
found that has agreed they're gonna
rebuild the engine and I'm gonna drop a
little money on it but it's gonna be
completely rebuilt you know end to end
uh you know to tested tuned ready to go
so
um I'm just I'm on his list so you have
to so you have to drive an engine to St
Louis to get it rebuilt
Barry you going on that trip I know I'm
waiting for the I'm waiting for him to
ask yeah
[Laughter]
I'm great
I'm easy to get along with yeah man will
you guys do like a road trip podcast and
you know just you two just shooting the
[ __ ] hanging out in the car that could
be fun singing some songs thinking oh
you could you could be singing some
editor songs yeah editors which by the
way I put I put an editor song on my uh
mixtape
did you really oh I didn't know that
um so how long is it gonna how long is
it gonna take to uh to rebuild the
engine I don't know he's probably gonna
take about a month for him turnaround
time
um yeah I I got referred to him through
a guy that lives around here he has a
bus and he takes it on the road nine
months out of the year at least he's in
Arizona right now and he's just had
nothing but good things to say about his
engine that he got built and he's like
I've you know driven it through like 43
States and not had any problems
if if it works out for him I think it's
going to work out for me and I think the
timing is going to be good where we can
get it dropped off you'll get it back
absolutely yeah that's the point okay
all right good it better be oh no yeah
plus better yeah if it doesn't go I
don't go
all right uh next week we'll talk to you
uh then I appreciate you guys
[Music]
consequence podcast Network